YUFENG GUO: Hi, my
name is Yufeng Guo,
and today we're
going to look at how
TensorFlow Enterprise, or TFE,
builds on TensorFlow to enable
the seamless creation of
production machine learning
applications with
enterprise-grade support,
through the power
of Google Cloud.
To learn about the
benefits of TFE,
let's imagine a scenario where
a data scientist visits an Ops
team to ask for help
productionizing their machine
learning platform.
The question then
becomes whether there
is a suitable platform for both
experimentation and production.
TensorFlow Enterprise is ideal
for this kind of situation.
Google Cloud has your
solution to productionize
your TensorFlow applications.
As part of Google Cloud, TFE
provides managed services,
cloud scale performance, and
enterprise-grade support.
Let's start with
managed services
and check back in to see how
our data science and Ops teams
are doing.
The data science team needs
development environments
with lots of compute power.
And in an on-prem,
non-managed system,
the burden of setting them up
often falls to the Ops team.
There are many challenges
to operating this way.
Machines with GPUs are
expensive and take a long time
to acquire.
Software installation
and management
consumes significant time.
Additionally, there's the
problem of over-provisioning.
This kind of
non-managed ML platform
doesn't scale for
enterprise-production projects.
One solution to
these constraints
is to introduce
a standardized ML
platform for the data
scientists and Ops teams
to solve these problems.
Enter TensorFlow Enterprise on
the Deep Learning VM, or DLVM.
The VM is a standardized VM
image for machine learning
applications.
TFE currently supports
TensorFlow 1.15 and two.
The machine comes pre-installed
with the everyday tools
for data scientists, including
CUDA drivers, NumPy, Sklearn,
Pandas, and of course, Jupyter.
Since it's a standardized
software stack,
it's easily manageable
by Ops engineers.
The DLVM is deployable
to Google Cloud,
with Google Compute Engine
or AI Platform Notebooks
in just a few minutes.
Also, there's no
over-provisioning problem,
because you will only
pay for the resources
you actually use,
minute by minute.
Let's take a look at how you
can actually create a GCE
instance with the DLVM image.
In the GCP console, head on
over to the Compute Engines,
VM Instances page,
and click Create.
Select Marketplace from
the left-hand menu,
and type Deep Learning
VM in the search bar.
Select the Deep Learning
VM and click Launch.
In this menu, you can
select your machine type
and if you want GPUs.
You can also select the
TensorFlow Enterprise,
versions 1.15 and two.
For now, let's choose
TensorFlow 1.15, without GPUs,
and just one CPU, a very simple
image, and just click Deploy.
The manageability you just
saw increases the portability
and scalability that you just
can't get with local notebooks.
There's often a huge gap between
proof of concept notebooks
and production
machine learning code.
For example, notebooks
are often particular
to the local environment
of each data scientist.
But production code should
be portable and shareable.
A single notebook instance
can't serve 10 million users.
The Ops teams have to
take on a lot of work
to scale and load balance to
build a production system.
Proof of concepts are
manually deployed,
whereas in production,
the Ops team
needs to manage a reproducible
end-to-end lifecycle.
And after all of
that, continuous
monitoring and
alerting still need
to be taken into consideration.
One way to fill the gap between
experimentation and production
is Deep Learning
Containers, or DLC,
with TensorFlow Enterprise.
DLC provides the exact same
standardized ML software
stack as a DLVM, with support
for TensorFlow 1.15 and two,
as well as lots of common
data size libraries.
But now it's on a portable
and scalable container image.
If your data science team
is already using DLVMs,
then it's much easier
for Ops engineers
to migrate their code
to DLC, and deploy it
to Google Cloud Services, such
as AI Platform and Kubernetes
Engine.
With Deep Learning
Containers the Ops team
won't have to add
100,000 lines of code
to make a robust system.
For example, if you use AI
Platform or a Kubernetes engine
to run the container,
you automatically
get the benefits from
the managed service,
such as container scheduling and
lifecycle management, scaling
out to load balancing
and failover, logging
and monitoring, troubleshooting,
security, and more.
Now let's see how scale Cloud
Performance of TensorFlow
Enterprise can benefit you.
In many cases, data
scientists tend
to use smaller sample
data sets for building
their machine learning
models, and don't bother
handling the raw big data.
So it falls to the Ops team
to design an ML pipeline that
can accommodate the 10
million rows from storage
without any I/O bottleneck,
and continuously
and smoothly pre-process and
train the model every day.
Because TensorFlow Enterprise
provides TensorFlow runtimes
specifically designed
for Google Cloud,
you can fully utilize the cloud
scale performance of both Cloud
Storage and BigQuery
with minimal changes
to your existing
TensorFlow code.
Lastly, let's talk about
enterprise-grade support.
The pace of AI and software
versions is evolving rapidly,
and it's hard to keep up with
new library versions always
coming out.
That is why
TensorFlow Enterprise
includes long-term support.
For TensorFlow 1.15
and two, Google Cloud
will provide security
patches and select bug fixes
for up to three years.
These versions will be
available on Google Cloud,
and all patches and
bug fixes will also
be available in the mainline
TensorFlow repository.
TensorFlow Enterprise
is available today
with support for
TensorFlow 1.15 and two.
Speed up your
software development,
and ensure the longevity
and reliability
of your AI applications
and services
with enterprise-grade support.
It's the only offering
from the same team
that created TensorFlow.
Head over to
g.co/cloud/TensorFlow to get
started today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]